okay so your dad cool points we're all
ready right here with me and they just
skyrocketed with the post you just
posted oh yeah every and how cool you
think she is in her rocket I mean I
think everybody would think that was
cool I mean it was one of those things
that I'm just like watching her and
she's an alone group of kids and it's
how they say be quiet I'd like at
assembly and and she's just the lone one
just like just holding it up and just
being solid about it like real calm
solidarity it's funny because I think
Jenna told us once about taking her to
ballet class and how all the other kids
were doing that and she was like in the
corner life she's like on the ground
rolling around like I'm saying
every kid is up doing like like the
proper sup and she's just doing her own
thing okay so those memes it's just like
I do it I want and it's just like
everyone's doing the same thing there's
one kid on the ground you guys are
teaching her to be an individual already
and that says something about the fact
that she's so young and already figuring
out like how to be her own woman yeah I
mean she kind of came out that way I
wish I could like take credit for that
but I can't really I mean that's that's
really all her like she's just I think
kids sort of do come out a little bit of
what they're gonna be and then you
foster that to be whatever you know you
hope her to be in the world she always
was just like does her own thing I wish
I could take credit for that book the
talk in the et offices they want a
Channing Tatum album that was a whole
thing I would just mimic all of them
like a bunch of people I would try to
like I don't know I would
because I couldn't actually mimic
anybody did you reinforce that I need
Lakers tickets to LeBron today I did I
was like I was like so you got the you
got the me you okay cool he's like yeah
I got you yeah I don't know he probably
that's the 12 other people right that
was there's probably a bunch of people
behind me doing the same thing
[Music]
[Applause]